all right so listen we had a um i asked
him if he's gotten you in trouble with
the irs yet uh
so what the [ __ ] explain your jewelry
because you said that you didn't get to
go all the way in
explaining how to write off jewelry to
the irs
tax season just passed well we're in it
right now
give us the full explanation how does
one write off jewelry okay so i mean so
one i made a mistake last time i called
it a mineral it's a metal so like gold
and silver is a precious metal
so like the same way the irs looks at
property whatever it may be like it's
it's all classifications for everything
right so with anything obviously if you
got a diamond if you got a diamond bust
down gold chain gold is no longer a
value in the same way right go has to be
like a whole object round they got i
mean i know you always see like coins on
the internet and stuff like that break
your brick right coins just like they
classified as a round or flat metal
pretty much so that's one two it's like
buying or selling
anything of
value like an asset like a house so if
you buy
they have what's called a fnv i'm
actually pull that up so you can
actually so i could read that to you but
because i don't know that by heart but
fmv is a fair mark fair market value and
you pretty much subtract the price of
what it was originally purchased by
to the very market value yeah so and is
that the amount you could write off so
yeah yeah so you take the amount so
let's say if you sell it or
if you receive it either way right you
take the value of what it currently is
versus the value of what it was bought
for and that difference is what you
pretty much can write off but the gold
once you put diamonds in it it doesn't
you you're it's it's it did it it
decreases disqualifies holes in it and
they don't have to yes so you got to
have like because i know people who
literally like buy like
silver uh these the silver bars
yeah the bars are silver
bars of gold and they'll just put them
in there safe yeah yeah it's considered
an investment by the irs so like the irs
is not like people would be saying like
oh like you're you're you're you're uh
your chain right yeah the actual chain
yeah it's just solid gold that's a solid
gold yeah so that's okay i wrote that
off there it is yeah so but so blast is
not funny he's [ __ ] no not really no
no no no no no no it's a lot of diamonds
[ __ ] and you got so then you got other
other ways right so as an artist you
have people that'll be like i have
costume fees
right and you have costume fees you can
buy jewelry which are costume fees for a
music video an appearance whatever that
may be and within that costume fee if
you purchase some jewelry with under
that purchase then you can write that
off because obviously you're writing it
off in your taxes saying that that's
just a business expense that's part of
your car or a marketing expense because
it's your label exactly so it's
different though because if i write off
gold that's like okay that's like
registered as a piece of property to me
once i appraise it so then when i turn
in my gold if i sell the gold i can get
that tax deduction if i sell it right
him he can't get the sale part you feel
me he can write off the purchase part
but not the reselling of it